oggi vorrei parlarvi di quello che il
patrimonio culturale fa per la comunità
partendo da due assunti uno quello che è
il patrimonio culturale ci sono molte
definizioni di ogni tipo per
identificarlo
in definitiva è comunque ciò che è
riuscito per la sua bellezza artistica o
per il suo valore storico ad
attraversare il tempo è stato ritenuto
degno di essere conservato fino a noi e
l'altro assunto è che questo patrimonio
culturale fa qualcosa di buono per di
bello per la nostra vita
questo lo diamo per scontato non è di
questo che voglio convincerlo che voglio
parlare con voi ma di come la distanza
che spesso si crea tra oggi tra quello
che dovrebbe fare bene a noi quindi il
patrimonio culturale e come lo viviamo e
quanto appunto è distante da noi sgombro
subito il campo anche dal comparto
turistico il patrimonio culturale è
molto spesso una risorsa turistica
meno male che lo è ma non è quello di
cui parliamo noi oggi noi parliamo di
ciò che il patrimonio culturale di una
comunità fa per quella comunità
sceglierò quindi degli esempi che
afferiscono al nostro territorio ciò che
il patrimonio culturale del nostro
territorio fa per noi questa è una mensa
è un dipinto il cenacolo vinciano lo
riconosciamo tutti nasce per essere
viene dipinto all'interno di un
refettorio quindi in un posto dove ogni
giorno ci si reca a mangiare e anche
questa è una mensa è un'immagine né
troppo edulcorata né troppo
resa della somma negativa di una mensa
scolastica questo è il posto dove i
nostri figli mangiano ogni giorno e
probabilmente anche qualcuno di noi ha
mangiato ogni giorno ecco dovremmo
chiederci se preferiamo mangiare qui
oppure qui
eppure siamo in grado di fare entrambe
le cose non è e non è un invito a
realizzare ristoranti in tutti i luoghi
storici del nostro del nostro territorio
che sarebbe una tentazione sicuramente
molto forte anche economicamente molto
valida ecco non è questo ma è l'invito
ad avere cura degli spazi dove noi
trascorriamo la nostra quotidianità o
parte della nostra quotidianità e a
includere tra questi spazi anche quello
che consideriamo che definiamo
patrimonio culturale perché se lasciamo
che si crei troppa distanza fra il
nostro vivere quotidiano e il patrimonio
culturale che abbiamo detto che ciò che
ci fa stare bene e che ci dice chi siamo
perché oggi siamo questo rischiamo di
perdere il senso di uscire anche da un
continuum storico quindi guardiamo solo
oggi ma non riconosciamo più chi siamo e
probabilmente anche dove vogliamo andare
vi presento tre esempi molto molto
locali uno e questo parliamo del isolino
virginia quella che vedete una mappa
storica del lago di varese l'unica isola
del lago di varese al isolino virginia
oggi è un patrimonio dell'umanità per la
storia che ha vissuto 7 mila anni fa un
tempo molto distante da noi in cui
l'uomo sceglie di insediarsi su
quest'isola creando delle palafitte lo
fa a varese lo fa in tutto l'arco alpino
di questo sito unesco fanno parte c'è
più di 100 siti in tutto l'arco alpino
c'è un problema che se io vi invito a
visitare le palafitte
e voi mi seguite probabilmente sulla
fiducia non vedrete le palafitte resti
lignei sono sotto il pelo dell'acqua non
si percepisce nulla
la risposta che nella maggior parte dei
casi avrò è quella del non vedo nulla
non lo capiscono lo comprendo quindi non
mi serve ma se io vi invito a fare una
gita in barca
probabilmente la maggior parte di voi
saranno
disponibili mediamente a seguirci perché
l'acqua dell'evento che ci fa stare bene
ovviamente per andare sull'isola abbiamo
bisogno di una piccola tragitto
sull'acqua se poi lo faccio offrendovi
anche un paesaggio uno spettacolo
naturale positivo questa è la fioritura
di fiori di loto che si verifica sul
lago di varese
ogni anno probabilmente vi offrirò di
far stare bene voi vivrete quel momento
come qualcosa che vi fa stare bene
sarete quindi disponibili a entrare in
questa storia e anche a chiedervi perché
lì quell'isola cosa è successo in
quest'isola chi prima di me è stato bene
in quest'isola non ho fatto nulla di
speciale se non fornire una chiave di
accesso un pochino più semplice rispetto
a un contenuto complesso che è la storia
degli ultimi 7 mila anni del nostro
territorio e della nostra vicenda umana
il secondo esempio riguarda il parco
valle dell'ansa è un territorio naturale
attraversato dal torrente lanza
comprende cinque comuni malnate cagno
rodero bizzarrone valmorea provincia di
varese como al confine con la svizzera
questo è proprio uno dei cancelli che
ancora oggi segnano il confine su quel
su quel territorio nel 2018 i comuni ci
hanno chiesto di organizzare delle
attività che celebrassero i 15 anni di
vita del parco abbiamo strutturato una
decina di incontri che riguardavano
escursioni dialoghi come questa insomma
vari momenti e sono stati incontri molto
partecipati tant'è vero che poi lo
abbiamo replicato con altre modalità
quest anno e probabilmente lo
replicheremo anche il prossimo anno
qual è stata in questo caso la chiave di
successo a mio avviso abbiamo parlato di
un tema che apparteneva alla vita
quotidiana di tutte le persone che hanno
partecipato abbiamo parlato di confini e
stavamo stiamo parlando di confini ogni
giorno nella nostra comunità però qui lo
abbiamo fatto abbiamo potuto farlo
offrendo una prospettiva storica che
rendesse il tema in qualche maniera
neutro parlavamo del confine italo
svizzero del confine geografico
amministrativo ma anche culturale un
confine che adesso ovviamente non è
sotto pressione ma che è stato sotto
pressione
e che ha vissuto momenti difficili e
questo quindi ci ha permesso di entrare
nella vita delle persone senza toccarlo
eccessivamente senza essere invasivi in
più le persone sentivano parlare di
qualcosa che faceva parte anche della
loro storia familiare perché degli
spalloni che portavano i materiali in
maniera i prodotti in maniera illecita
tra un lato e l'altro del confine quasi
tutte le persone di quel comune hanno
sentito parlare o hanno bisogno
esperienze familiari di una o al massimo
due generazioni precedenti
quindi si sono sentiti parte di questa
storia il terzo esempio è il sacro monte
di varese è un luogo che non ha tanto
bisogno di presentazioni almeno per noi
varesini lo conosciamo tutti ma quando
lo costruimmo 400 anni fa agli inizi del
sicuramente le istanze che ci hanno
portato costruirlo sono molto diverse da
quelle che oggi ci portano a
frequentarlo la motivazione di allora
era esclusivamente di fede e devozione
la motivazione di oggi e anche in alcuni
casi di fede e devozione ma ci sono
tante altre motivazioni allora perché se
non riconosciamo più quella motivazione
comunque lo frequentiamo perché offre
qualcosa alla nostra vita risponde a
delle esigenze della nostra vita che
sono quelle di muoversi di avere uno
spazio e un tempo per la contemplazione
ma anche per il movimento per la
curiosità per la scoperta che sono tutte
esigenze fondamentali e nate nella
nostra natura e questa disponibilità
questa risposta è aperta sempre il viale
del rosario non ha un orario potete
accedere quando volete
allora abbiamo applicato questo
semplicissimo principio anche alla vita
dei musei di sacro monte per cui è
bastato spostare un pochino gli orari
d'estate gli apriamo di sera perché il
nostro tempo dedicato al pensiero alla
contemplazione alla
tranquillità non è quello lavorativo ma
quello che arriva alla sera oppure
abbiamo offerto la possibilità di
consumare drink piuttosto che di
intrattenersi con degli amici in spazi
che solitamente non sono destinati a
questo non per dire che è un luogo così
banale così semplice che li si può fare
tutto ci puoi bere ci puoi fare tutte le
attività quotidiane ma perché è uno
spazio che certo ti chiede un minimo di
regole ma è per te e accogliente fa per
te quello di cui tu hai bisogno in più
poi ti travolge con la sua bellezza la
sua storia la sua conoscenza e ti
racconta che ancora oggi può essere per
te torno alle mense questa è la prima
mensa questa è la seconda vi chiederei
se avreste preferito trovando in quel
momento investire in questa mensa o in
questa e se siamo sicuri siamo certi che
questo sia costato più di questo non è
detto provo a proporvi un esempio
diciamo di medio livello visto che il
cenacolo magari oggi lo consideriamo un
pochino inarrivabile questa è la messa
di sal alba è una sala che si trova ad
olgiate olona decorata da uno dei
maggiori disegnatori italiani antonio
rubino
tra l'altro con una motivazione sulla
politica di quel momento molto forte
ospitava i bambini di un istituto che si
occupava di infanzia con problemi di
tubercolosi e questa è la decorazione
della mensa questo è accaduto
una settantina di anni fa quindi non
tanto distanti da noi vuol dire che lo
possiamo fare che qualcosa ancora di
molto vicino a noi anche perché nel
mondo dei beni culturali lavorano
altissime professionalità
abbiamo sufficienti competenze
conoscenze e strumenti per far sì che le
imprescindibili esigenze conservative
vadano di pari passo con l'uso di questi
spazi sono e vogliamo che le persone
considerino il loro patrimonio culturale
parte della loro vita dobbiamo
permettergli di viverlo di fare qualcosa
dentro a questi luoghi
allora magari non nel cenacolo che ha
delle esigenze di conservazione
preponderanti rispetto all'uso ma in
tutti gli altri luoghi sì si può fare è
la cosa che serve a far avvicinare le
persone semplicemente proporgli una
chiave di accesso comprensibile che gli
faccia capire che quel luogo e anche per
loro
nella mia attività quotidiana durante
l'anno incontro ci incontriamo e tra
come azienda tra le 60 e 80 mila persone
che visitano luoghi culturali
abbiamo il dovere di consegnare a quelle
persone una chiave di accesso possibile
comprensibile non banale ma
comprensibile che permetta loro di
rientrare in questa storia è proprio per
questo che dobbiamo investire nuovamente
in questo ambito e mi piacerebbe
invitare tutti voi nel vostro ruolo
decisionale o nel vostra attività
quotidiana a dedicare investimenti tempo
e scelte a ciò che possiamo fare per il
patrimonio culturale del nostro
territorio
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]